I am back. Oh, did you miss me? Did you I'm sure you did. Thank you for joining me on this journey
being part of the daily routine
Playing some South Park. Why can I not spend like a normal person?
This should not be this hard. Oh my god
Just how much do I got a spin, are you kidding me? Are you serious you can't look at this spinning perfect action
Alright I had to actually spin
You best be quiet boy
Okay, you best be quiet
Hello
Hello, everybody mina-san
Have you have it's my birthday today when I'm recording this at least
Spoilers. I'm a day ahead of you guys
Happy birthday to me everyone. Thank you
What better day way to spend your day than to play?
Some self pake okay our goal is to go back to our house. I'd forgotten okay there we go
We are at 100% underleveled
But I'm not playing a hardest difficulty anymore, so I think we'll be fine
It's just I was spending so much time and ease each fight like I think I spent 40 minutes on Sam
I
Don't really have that kind of time
As much as I enjoyed like they're really difficult comment. This is my house shut up
Oh, yeah
To deal with you that marijuana is changing you somehow
I'm not telling everyone our child secret. Oh he paranoid some more in your room. What is the secret?
Another drink oh hey there pumpkin pie Oh
Daddy's gonna go upstairs to his room mommy's gonna go get a drink
What is wrong with my parents, there's a secret whaling to be revealed
Go to my room and sleep not even supper. What is this?
terrible family
Did not make they took my jerk
They took my really my parents gave me the Swedish candy, and I've already finished all of it. I'm so sad
My birthday is ruined God be a
Bat up when we get a lot of stuffing knees I
should actually
Swap out some
We're supposed. Are we unlocked another slide, okay? Well then I think we're not underleveled anymore look. Yeah, we're almost 500
Bars Inga, okay come on if we can get to 500 that would be awesome I
Think we can't okay well close enough go to bed. Let's go
Forget about the light I who cares
No you didn't you clearly didn't
Fording so much
Go on down and eat your supper champ, hahaha
Okay, so probably they are the ones making as far to our parents are
Putting some medicine in our food with side effects that gives us real superpowers if only life
Would be real. Oh never go see. I can't help myself
Oh
Poor young man and boy is something in between
Scandinavian
Does it be sad what is that food? Anyway? What does that food supposed to be?
Why did we go to bed without eating food as well
See I called it
That's right. I'm two steps ahead
Two steps ahead left and right up and down
bottoms up
I'm again. It's another name in staff peak
This time it's real okay get dressed and meet me out front hurry the night awaits
For that cool alright, what apparently you got to spin it like crazy oh
I don't understand like I'm spinning so fast. I'm spinning faster
I know well like what I'm spinning like crazy. Ah
We have transformed, I don't like this outfit anymore, let's craft a new one what do you say a berserker?
Let it out those aren't costumes
We could get the Norse helmet. That would be dope
Starchild yeah, there's a pretty game
It's not that there's anything wrong with that of course
Okay
What did we get?
These are terrible
You know what let's go back to the old classic
Fuck you Ubisoft with you
seriously
All you have to join our club to get this outfit. Oh
You want to join our club will Ubisoft join our club?
Please join our clubs
You'll get an outfit
No, thank you who bisa
It's at that time you know how hard it is to look mysterious when you're just standing around in some kids front yard
It's pretty fucking hard
I'm glad you're with us new kid
It's been tough being the only one on the team with real superpowers
While all the other kids are playing and working on their franchise plans
I'm stuck defending the city against evil with barely any time to work on my pitch for a mysterion spin-off movie
Sometimes it feels like a curse 70-pound wait. What is his powers because you're like me
I'm sure the power of your ass weighs heavy on you. Not really and it gets released
you know
What happened that night?
Gina oh
Yeah something happens at night
No, that's that's definitely normal
Hey guys, what is up?
Once we get inside the police station toolshed at the new kid will set up a diversion in done wait
What the fuck yeah, come on guys hey?
We've got to get inside to put these days
So do you assholes do mine we're here to investigate a hot lead regarding these South Park Police
Doing oh no no
No, this is our superhero mission freedom pass fuck you guys to us before there's a fight fellas fellas have we all forgotten
There's a little girl in trouble in there fastpasses rat
I suppose that just this once we should put our petty differences aside and work together
This all right mysterion. What did the plan I?
Think some of us should cause a diversion
Make the cops head towards it so the rest of us can sneak in without the cops noticing good idea
Current friends will go up the fire escape and cause a diversion so freedom pals can sneak in the front
This is all pretty coincidental
Did you guys just steal our lead again innocent people are being arrested Jewish ed yeah?
That's all that matters to us should be all that matters to you. Okay one safe
Sleep on me stand by we gotta wait for the diversion come take a look at this
Okay
Man that's strong shit
You know just coke seem a little off to you. No. No, this is sweet. You guys want to call some hookers
What the fuck is that come on let's check it out bring the coke?
Tax money well spend every one right come on the coast is clear
He's gonna let us
Oh wow I didn't see that coming me neither wait. What is this photograph? Ah?
Shit ourselves, oh wow they're really strung
There it is
There we go that should make it a little easier let's kill him
No cell phone cameras gonna save you this time I
Like the seventies me 80s music very nice
No not more
What does that mean what does that mean?
Oh my god
They get stronger because of token
Okay, we haven't used mysterious old, so let's try it out
Yeah, Oh, what the heck sorry what just happened
It's mysterion Kenny's became a ghost why is he a ghost I'm so confused
What the heck was up with mr.. What have I missed there find classy that poor innocent girl shouldn't do anything
except
Doing drugs and prostitution
Look I know why you're here you fed up because you think all cops do is harass black people
That's what you send us out to do
I know that to a young kid it can seem like cops are racist and bigoted, but you can't believe what the media tells you
Cops are just people like you your friends your family people who work hard
Get over yourself token he shot at tweek come on, but those cops need a main
Observation room maybe we can find some guns
Soft room oh wow this place makes me feel very uncomfortable
Tokens in here let's go. Oh my bad. What in the world is happening there? We go that looks like an override switch
Well it must be impossible even my temperatures can't take on something like that oh
It's a pause spell they left these
Here we go everybody we got four seconds three seconds to say oh my god there we go I did it
Must be some kind of genius
We can just go here
Hey look at that everybody we did it
Hey this time we need hamster
He's so cute stop
Forgot that that was what happens
Works every time do we have to go down all the way, okay?
Yeah, I'm coming
Just give me one moment. Please think oh I missed a boxer who cares
When you bothered by this does this bother you well, that's too bad, okay, I can't do anything everything what should I?
Get zero tolerance just like I got zero definite plate
Oh
Hey, you're the one who got me put in here what yes, you're on the wrong side of history young whatever you are
It wasn't me I swear
Oh my god, Oh, No well it looks like we got it beat up some racist caps
Are they all targeting token that would be hilarious
Poor token
They don't know always attack your token whatever listen. I thought it would be a good meme, but clearly it wasn't about game
Hey got them all
When we shot scare PewDiePie season 2
one of the
one of the scenes was in a prison like this and
I
Almost liked those gates things they open all together
And I had my hand in the cell like as a meme
While they open it and my hand got stuck
And it was just about to like squeeze it to the point where I would at legit just break my hand
Luckily, they stopped it like right in time, but it was pretty fucking close man
Kind of thing you will never see, but what can you do alright? We're done here clean up boys I
Haven't seen what mysterion does when he's a ghost, but we'll save it for another time. I suppose a
Rat a rat Iraq another battle defeated
Ok ok I know this looks bad. You really think cops just go around arresting black people for no reason
Purpose could that possibly serve it's reverse discrimination
That's what it is if we were all black cops and our jails were filled with white people nobody would say a word
So I guess you've learned that the real bigots. Here. Are you?
Kids guess you can all go home no fuck
Well I guess we loot this guy
Sorry for being bigoted that's open
We're innocent so breaking out of jail isn't a crime right? I'm not sticking around to find out
I smelled a class-action lawsuit supreme court here. We come token. What did I tell you about playing too rough mom?
I was defending justice I don't care what you were defending. You could have gotten hurt. I could wear khaki
He's impervious to pain is he impervious to getting his butt spanked
No, that's right
Depends still spank their kids, but what the heck?
That's not very Christian. No like that all right. Let's get that cop Overlord guy thingy
Are they just like tokens anyway? They just let token continued nay. We can blow this up
I don't know why I did that
Maybe I can move the propane tank
Well well well I could move the propane tank I
Must be some sort of genius
I know that's what you're thinking right? How does it solve the puzzle with such elegance and eloquence and other words I?
know
It's my Swiss chin. I can't happen. It's comes naturally
like the parts of but Lord
We got a pristine costume how about that?
Okay, so it's stuck
Man I am really dumb
Anyway yeah me neither oh
My god. It's one of those spam things of course. I can use fucking oh
I can use Kyle here come on
Wait
Oops, sorry about that wasn't focused
Cash man's bitch is a big fat, bitch
Nothing like some good parkour, okay?
Now we can do the power switch got it
hamster go I
Don't know what I think about this whole buddy thing
Usually usually they they put them in games as a way to like
Go through areas that you couldn't go through before but it just seems like a way to prolong the gameplay
I'm sure there's some stuff back. Yeah, anyway, we did it
Now how do we get down there?
okay, I
Guess we got a jump hardcore down again
Okay
Okay well glad we did that tokens already left excellent, maybe the cop got him
Edgar's glue what the heck is?
What is he doing ill yeah, he'll
Stop
All right can't stand here no
Really it is charged, okay
Okay
Disgusting this game is disgusting despicable, but I love it
Wow Wow
That's what we did. We move the monitor everyone with a fart. I suppose we have to do the same over here. No oh
my god
Bye
Master puzzle solver everyone
That's me know what a cop is new kid huh a cop is a slave a robot was told not to think for himself
It's the politicians who are the real bigots that mayor has been sitting in her office telling us we have to change our ways
The only way to have her removed was to raise crime in the streets and now cops are finally able to do things the old
Way again, don't you see this is better for everyone?
We found him
Freedom fells, we've got the police sheet top floor
What can I say you kids have me by the balls
Almost by the balls all the most you know not every prisoner. We have here is black
We actually do have one white guy. Oh my god. Who is it?
Oh my god. This is a trap. I'm sorry kids, but you left me no choice and Terry
Oh, it's a sandwich subway
Hey kids you want some candy oh fuck it's Jared
You'll excuse me if I don't want to watch this so Jared was like for those who don't know you probably know
He was his face for Subway
Because he lost a lot of weight
supposedly eating Subway's
yourself and then he turned out to be a pedophile I
Can't attack anything, but him here this sucks. He'll oh
Oh my god
Make way for mysterion, can you see really no one can attack because he has that thing they?
What is he gonna do i'm reaiiy legit scared
That's a microaggression, what do you mean?
What do you mean I need to eat
Oh my god here, there's a lot of that. Oh, that's disgusting. I'm gonna rewind
All right, what do we got no?
No don't hey Lynn
We'll handle these kids for you. He's giving us candy
What a waste have something sweet, what in the world
Wow he does a lot of damage stop oh my god
Just don't heal him just oh wait he comes back just
Don't here
Yeah, all right nice, ooh
Almost in your level what close main, we're close
New kid partners face
That's there's more cells down below cops take that elevator prisoners go down there, but they don't come back. What's the code?
Come on. How should I know huh?
Yeah, I see them type it in 1 4 7 7 please. I'm sorry
It's just that I like being with children. You know because because I never had a childhood of my own
Yeah, that's it. I like kids cuz I never had a childhood. It's your decision
New kid being a superhero is deciding what to do it moments like these. Oh, we're definitely gonna fart in his face
As easy check
Wasn't that hard car I expected more of a buildup alright? Well that was pretty uncomfortable, I know being a vector for disease
It's kind of my thing, but I I feel kind of dirty should we do anything? What is he dead?
Yeah
Okay, let's find cheap Casey. Oh wait
What's over here
That's something you don't see every day a Ford execution well, okay, if you're pointing to kill Murphy cami this must be him
No, oh yeah, there was the pass code one four seven seven what did she say one four seven seven
four takes serve bang bang
This is a one-time shot Coon after tonight
We are enemies again our petty little differences aren't what matter right now mysterion black lives matter. Yeah, dick. You're a fucking dick mosquito
Let's go open the gate, what in the world is happening here?
It's a code well things got real spooky caring for your elder God here
Hey look at my new outfit pretty, dope huh, okay? Let's go to anymore oh?
No oh
No, this is not good
PewDiePie is gonna. Come out as the villain of it all oh
We can drag this one
Don't know what I just grabbed, but you know come on there must be something else here
Are you serious
Why not we go forensic first?
What was that what is this hello
Hello, someone there. No. I guess no one's there, or else. They would have said something
Yes, just me and you kitty oh, no no one's gonna find us in here come on. Give me that good stuff
Nanus the cat got away, no we needed stupid cat hang in here
It sounds like the cat's getting into the toxic chemicals darn it. That's not good I
Hope those weren't the toxic chemicals I was just talking about that broke on the flow just now oh
No, I think they were drat those chemicals mixed together on the floor it'll turn into a gas that will kill me in seconds
Blast it. There's the gas yes
It's definitely killing me now
Well, thank God
Now where's that?
I think the into the killing me again
Yeah
I'm we can't do anything by the way
Thank you for turning on the light appreciate it can we save his lap yes perhaps, there's still chance I
Wasn't me I swear now shove the thing up my butt. Thank you. Thank you very much and here we go
What is that a chicken in the fan, oh it's oh no, he's stuck we got to save him
What is that random hand uh
We need something la chemise Long's
Time farts, thank God we had time farts. What would I possibly do without it?
There it is okay now we get there half the gas actually we might need to
Fight fire with fire or fourths with parts as one would say
Oh is that don't tell me the cat is dead not after all of this
Please sparkles no I can't touch him anyway
Or is that something else?
Wait what
No, there's no. That's another cat is there something here. Oh, yeah, we never see these
But it's for Captain diabetes I
Forgot, I forgot about his power
This is the weird one man, I mean they're all weak
Thank you we got the skeleton key everyone. Oh, okay that means we can keep going
And then we've been in the morgue yeah, okay skeleton Tequila there's all police officers have one of these
It must be a standard building isn't it?
Oh these awkward moments in the loading screen haven't you missed them, it's just great
Wait what do they say that it's not questions your faithful servants the Destroyers of light
Yeah, yeah shut african american slang word. Rev Black Goat of 1000 morbid young draw down the moon and distinguish the Sun
All right now. I rap put him in the ho about oh, it is an action
oh
I see I guess because cops feed
African-americans to an elder god. They're
Racist some african american slage word off is an outer God kids who must be a piece and whose coming was foretold by the great HP
Lovecraft, but I suppose HP Lovecraft was a race as you oh
Fuck was he really like
Like I didn't know that
Let's end it all right, you kids want a battle. Let's do this here it comes
Defeat chub neighborette
Okay Chuck another one in no not kz o
Shove neighbor and oh wow that is that is quite something
Yes star token
You will be we need to push them into their into the neighbor ranch I
Don't know which one of us have knocked back spells or did we just kill them
The Heretic has cursed me
Let's end our round here. I'm not your worst nightmare. I aspire to be and there hopefully this is not crack
It doesn't
No point as if your life wasn't already spinning out of control
No well you bring harm to the goat with a thousand young I'm here to protect the night queen
Why does he keep sniffing the cat did I?
Hey Johnson
There's a tricky one in it
Okay, I get it I get I just got to keep feeding it to him doesn't matter if I kill longer
So we just got to do one more, and we should be all clear
Here we are finally that was I don't have any knock back spells. I only have one with my character
So that was a lot harder than it needs to be
But hey we did it everyone and the spirit of Christmas mostly. Hey, we unlocked another spot. It's about a heck yeah, man
That's what I'm talking about damn leveling up Dan Master
Look at that
Finally
She said neighbor
Wait what's going on? Where are you taking that cat?
Trophy earned an end to racism certain Intel we have that we can't share with you. You know it's that's bad
that's because we've been tricked ah
The new kid played us Freedom House wanting to join our side was a real. Oh my god
What yeah the new kid kind of totally fucked you guys over sorry
To the police station and now intend to get a hundred dollar reward for that missing cat well. All's fair in love and war freedom
You assholes we're the ones that stopped the police chief's evil plan we deserve that hundred dollar reward
Oh, yeah, just try to take it from us. We will
Civil War three it's going down. That's it. You'll kiss. We're gonna rip you apart no mysterion
We won't fight the new kid they will oh?
my
He's using mind-bending attacks
What is happening here
Sorry chaos unfortunately dr. Timothy can only dominate so many mites at once oh that makes sense
So I guess this is another one we have to get Timmy
Wow here's a ship by God, what do I?
Well these go down pretty quick did I just say quiet instead of wait well done me. Thank you very much
Oh, okay, let's drink one of these then
Okay, we only have Kyle left
Okay, everyone is everyone is out. Everyone's on us
Thank you, thank you very much, it's gonna be more
Now captain diabetes make up
The old-fashioned way what is that?
Special the objective defeat dr. Timothy we're gonna. Do it easy. Oh my god. He's gonna do a lot of damage in you
Know be mind controls. I hate it so annoying you know I'm gonna block that one
Just cuz I need I need everyone on my side yeah, turn denied
You're gonna heal
Oh, no what happened
I think the game froze, and I literally was just about to beat
No, come on. Dude. Are you kidding me this took so long? Oh?
No oh
My god finally
Just kind of annoying Howard fleshed out, but okay, we did it
What
Well what what happened how'd my lip get busted where the fuck did classy go dr. Timothy. Yeah, where's classy to be honest
He was trying to help us
Understand dr. Timothy was working on a way to save all of us freedom pals and Coon friends
What oh my god? Oh?
Easy doc you've taken a lot of hits
Wow this is your guy face, this is dick this looks like so much fun
Yeah, he's cool air has not closed that soon, but that is care dr. Timothy was never your enemy
He was trying to help us all but how with this
Oh my god, he had a plan for the franchise
It was doctor Timothy's passion
he worked tirelessly on it a
Franchise plan to involve everyone each hero got their own movie and TV series every hero mathematically equal to the other
So while we were out trying to stick it to you guys timmy was actually trying to include us yeah
And then this kid nearly killed him. We're sorry the new kid is an asshole that isn't our fault
Yeah, we were just using you guys
Who's paying hundred bucks for that cat
We are the best when we're all together
it's too late for that meals started as one team we all wanted to be superheroes for the same reason to
Sell our franchise and make millions of dollars. Let's be one team again. I agree come on guys no more Civil War
Let's get the reward money for this cat and you've been together for one franchise Nick. Let's do it, but we're calling it
freedom house
Freedom pals oh my god a Cartman is me Jimmy sort of the leader of freedom path
He's like don't he's like the one in charge. Yes
Well, I think it's awesome
Honestly freedom houses are way better name than Coon in France freedom
Freedom pass I'm super cool with this then itself tomorrow
We get the reward money for scrambles, and we use it to kick-start Timmy's franchise plan together Freedom House retribution
Inclusion fuck yeah you guys let's do this
Oh my god
But it wasn't that simple was it
What do we got here well, I'm gonna have to end this episode here this has been going on quite a while
Thank you guys for watching. I hope you enjoyed as always really appreciate it, and I'll see you next
Time I'm gonna enjoy my breath to neck goodbye squirt there